buckle up we're going to put all this in
perspective I know many of you you might
be worried about the ongoing political
tornados and hurricanes out of the swamp
in in Washington the mob and our corrupt
media by the way you should be it's
repulsive what they're doing again after
three years of Lies and conspiracy
theories now I can't tell you exactly
how it's all gonna play out and it's
likely maybe they go ahead and impeach
President Trump over nothing
Bill Clinton at 11 felonies in the Ken
Starr report nothing here we'll see but
I can tell you this tonight with
confidence I can tell you how this is
going to end and it's gonna end up with
the re-election of Donald Trump and in
part we are going to be able to thank
them for what they did and their
stupidity and their lack of concern for
you we the American people and I could
see the Republicans taking back the
house I could see Republicans increasing
their majority in the US Senate but make
no mistake about it these are dangerous
times for our constitutional republic by
the way god help us if they ever did win
with their 94 trillion dollar green New
Deal their thirty six trillion dollar
Medicare for all with no private
insurance yeah you see that would
destroy the greatest economy ever
designed by man that's a clear and
present danger Democrats they're
compliant lapdogs stenographers and the
mob and the media they are now willing
to shred the constitution up and the
rule of law suspend any connection to
truth reality objective truth and by the
way they'll cast away all god-given
common sense assuming they might have
had some in the beginning to subvert the
will of you we the American people the
root cause of this now going into
another impeachment saga it's not
bribery high crimes with misdemeanors
they don't have any of that instead it
is a psychotic hatred and rage against
this President and really for those of
us that put him in office and voted for
him in other words they never recovered
from losing in 2016 they thought they
had this covered make no mistake they
low
we you the american people we smelly
Walmart shoppers I love Walmart we
irredeemable deplorable z' you know
we're Americans that cling to our God
thank you our guns our Bible our
religion they hate you they hate me
they hate the president and they look
down on all of us they think they know
better and they want total control of
your life your decisions and they'll tax
you to death to get their scheme done
they want to confiscate our money they
want everything free free free for
everybody cradle cradle to grave wound
to to free Medicare free higher
education free child care free paid
vacation free housing free healthy food
free universal basic income whether
you're willing or unwilling to work and
by the way they'll eliminate oil gas the
combustion engines eventually planes in
cows and congresswoman Alexandria
Castillo Cortes the real Speaker of the
House now wants to provide this is the
truth welfare for illegal immigrants
including criminal illegal immigrants
those convicted this would cause an
economic devastation the likes of which
we the US and the world has ever
witnessed this is the greatest wealth
producing system in the world it would
be turned into another socialist tell no
different than Venezuela or Cuba but in
order to govern this country with
denying fists and carry out that
socialist dream of theirs they must
first reclaim power it's all about power
now you might say anything we have an
election in one year why not let the
American people decide well the answer
to that is they don't want to risk
another term of President Trump so they
feel like I gotta bludgeon and more
it'll backfire but that's their thinking
instinctively I argue they know they
can't win with the people they have
running congressman Al Green said it
best he's not impeach yeah it could get
reelected likely we'll take a look are
you concerned that impeachment talk may
actually help the president's
re-election
I'm concerned that if we don't impeach
this president he will get reelected if
we don't impeach him he will say he has
been vindicated
we don't impeach him he will get
reelected now what we have now been
through the last three years Russia
Russian peach and peach stormy stormy
it's now clear Democrats are fully
prepared to upend the will of the
American people by any means necessary
they think they know better than we do
and what by the way of the do-nothing
Democrats what have they done
what accomplishment have they made in
the last three years of Russia Russia to
make you we the American people more
prosperous to keep us more safe and more
secure they've done nothing this is all
they've done for three years they want
this post constitutional America they
want to stack the US Supreme Court
eliminate the electoral college so
California New Jersey New York and
Illinois will decide every national
election they want to get rid of a
president because they don't like him
and by the way even if he does something
they like they don't like him now what
the left does fail to realize time and
again is that well we might be
irredeemable deplorable that cling to
our God but we're also hard-working
logical smart Americans and we weren't
well swamped out of the common sense God
gave us we know what this impeach
impeachment inquiry is all about nothing
more than a political stunt they've
tried this for three years now they fail
by the way this time they're not gonna
they're not gonna put their faith and
hope in another special prosecutor who
in the end just let them down because
there was no evidence we have all
witnessed the lesson state insane
breathless non-stop three-year hoax
their lies their conspiracy theories and
their witch-hunt same people now same
agenda just a different country it's
Ukraine by the way Ukraine helped
Hillary Clinton in the last election
yeah and they admit it and by the way a
DNC operative subcontractor met with
Ukrainian official to get dirt on Trump
not telling that story either we the
people we have been watching and
witnessing this phony fake outrage this
media circus the character sash an
assassination this
smearing oh the president justice
Cavanaugh we witnessed a 16 year old
high school kid get demonized on
national TV for wearing a maggot hat
they assassinated his character you the
American people you've been witnessing
the media mobs and they are a mob with a
mob mindset breathless hysteria resulted
in one fake phony story after another
one lie after another every second of
every day we got him we got him we got
him no you don't the great irony and all
of this whatever accusations Democrats
and the mob launch against the president
they end up being guilty of that very
thing themselves how ironic this is why
tonight I want you to take a close look
at this list and by the way those
Democratic Congress men and women they
represent districts that President Trump
carried in 2016 now if you live in any
of those districts might be important to
remind you all lawmaker that they work
for you and not doing anything in three
years is not acceptable to you and to
allow the the corrupt cowardly atom the
shifty ship literally run this thing
these people need to stand up to this
post constitutional coup attempt in
their party and frankly I say defeat
them this is where you have the power
not them the radical far left extreme
socialist in charge of the Democratic
Party think they rule at all you will
have the last say at the end of the day
the Cowardly Schiff and AOC and Talib
and Omar and Pelosi speaker name only
they get their way the sanctity of your
vote the foundations of this great
prosperous Republic will be destroyed
because they want to fundamentally
drastically reshape America and Adam the
cowardly shifty ship well in particular
he's trying to con we the people with
outright lies and fabrications now we
know that the non whistleblower
whistleblower well from the Ukraine call
work with shifts office to craft the
complaint in fact shifts office
encourage the whistleblower to hire a
lawyer go to the Inspector General on
national TV the shifty shift well he
said we
have not spoken directly with the
whistleblower but we'd like - that was a
lie - maybe that's why the fake
whistleblower whistleblower failed to
mention his contact with ships office in
the complaint and according to a
reporter on Catherine Herridge this non
whistleblower and we have more because
that one's not panning out we have tons
of whistleblowers we'll make them up
filing this complaint left a blank
section which they could have disclosed
that congressional contact they didn't
use it still no word on why there was
also an 18-day gap in between the
president's call with Ukraine and the
urgent report made to the Inspector
General may be the Cowardly ship has not
been contacted by that point maybe he
knows the answer maybe shift can also
fill us in on why the fake phony non
whistleblower is reportedly a registered
Democrat hired to work in the Obama
White House went to his office of all
places to file his complaint
maybe the cowardly chef could tell us
how the president's phone calls with
world leaders are now getting leaked
again and again to the press Australia
Mexico
Ukraine Australia again no other
president in the history of this country
has had to deal with this onslaught from
a deep state bureaucracy swamped from
within only Donald Trump and now we're
seeing even more leaks from more
whistleblowers there's no end to the
whistleblowers that are not
whistleblowers that didn't work out
we'll find some more they don't need to
hear from anyone by the way because we
have a transcript doesn't matter what
they think or how they interpreted
hearsay information so to ship or anyone
in the swamp actually care about let's
see
real national security ramifications
what if the president needs to talk to a
world leader frankly about issues of war
and peace is that going to be spied on
to do they care about our diplomacy is
now in significantly impaired because of
these leaks clearly not now don't expect
to get an honest answer from ship or any
other Democrat for that matter and
certainly don't expect you're lying
corrupt mob media to ever do their jobs
the only thing they care about is taking
down Donald Trump no matter what undoing
an election of We the People
they're all proven liars every one of
them
the same players the same playbook just
a different country now it's Ukraine not
Russia and I can't think of a single
issue that they've not lied about our
own greg jarrett points out chip alone
lied about carter page getting bribed by
the kremlin he lied about the
dissemination of the dirty dossier
Schiff lied when he claimed that the
dirty dossier was not the bulk of
information in the FISA application
against Carter page to spy on a
candidate a transition team and then a
president and who could forget ship also
lied repeatedly alleging to have the
damning evidence proving Trump Russia
collusion that didn't work out did it as
a matter of fact four years there he is
the cowardly shifty ship while he's lied
over and over and over and over again
frankly not only censure he should not
be in charge of the intelligence
community really this guy take a look
yes there's ample evidence of collusion
in plain sight we've known for some time
at least it's been publicly reported
that the dossier or the hiring of
Christopher Steele was initially on
behalf of one of the Republican
candidates and later on behalf of the
Democratic candidate that application
and those renewals have been vindicated
in substantial part by Carter Paige's
own words well I certainly think he's
acting like someone who's compromised
and it may very well be that he is
compromised or may very well be that he
believes that he's compromised that the
Russians have information on him
according to Christopher Steele a
British a former British intelligence
officer who was reportedly held in high
regard by US intelligence Russian
sources tell him that Paige has also had
a secret meeting with Igor Sechin CEO of
the Russian gas giant Rosneft according
to Steel's Russian sources pages offered
brokerage fees by section on a deal
involving a 19% share of the company
I hear what you want I have a favor I
want from you though
and I'm going to say this only seven
times so you better listen good I want
you to make up dirt on my political
opponent understand lots of it on this
and on that he's a liar he's a
pathological frankly congenital liar
it's not just about the lies though it's
the complete and utter hypocrisy his
fellow Democrats the median mob they all
do the same thing
chef's alleged to have all the evidence
he's going to prove it Trump Russia
collusion but he's the guy caught on
tape trying to get dirt from somebody
that sounds like a Russian that he
thought wasn't Russian in fact he took
that direct call from two pranksters who
claimed to have naked pictures of tada
compromising materials from trauma he
thought the Ukrainians with connections
to Vladimir Putin anyone does Vladimir
know
yeah but the Vladimir know about the
compromising materials of AB naked rock
his colleague on the other side of the
aisle Mark Warner he isn't any better
remember after four separate
investigations no evidence of any
collusion including his own bipartisan
probe in the Senate Warner's still claim
the Trump might have colluded with
Russia anyway but at the very same time
whoopsie-daisy senator Warner was busy
texting a lobbyist for a Russian
oligarch to get dirt on Trump Warner
texting wanting the oligarch to help set
up a private meeting with none other
than Christopher Steele without any of
his Republican colleagues on the
committee knowing what their what
they're doing or what they accused Trump
of he actually texted the lobbyist for
the oligarch I would like to do prelim
you me no one else and water also
texting that he would rather have not
have a paper trail for his messages
colluding with the Russians senator
indicating that he would be willing to
travel abroad to meet with steel in
order to get the dirt on Trump and Matt
afford oh what they're blaming Trump up
now this is not a good look for someone
claiming a disavow all for an election
interference is it and he's not the only
democratic
senator guilty of doing that which
they're accusing Trump of that trumps
innocent of several months ago in
letters from Senator Menendez Durbin
Leahy the three Democrats threatened to
withhold aid if the government of
Ukraine stopped investigating Trump on
the Trump Russia side just this month in
meeting with Ukraine's new president
Solinsky
well Democratic Senator Chris Murphy
reportedly threatened to cut off US aid
if the country opened an investigation
into Biden and don't forget politico's
report about a DNC operative this was
January 11 2017 they wrote this an
operative working for the DNC a
contractor working with the Ukrainian
government to get compromised Athiya
deals to smear then candidate Trump and
bolster and help Hillary oh collusion
and according to The Wall Street Journal
the Clinton Foundation Wow they got a
more than fifty thousand dollars in
donations from Ukrainian citizens then
another than any other foreign country
imagine if vice president Trump not
Biden's son let's say it was hunter
Trump no evidence no background in
Ukraine or China and did what hunter did
while his dad was vice president but not
a word on any of this from your corrupt
mob and the media the only thing they do
the do-nothing Democrats the only care
about three years now getting rid of
Trump nothing else nothing else
meanwhile look at the president he's
been tirelessly working day after day
keeping his promises improving the lives
of We the People and we're seeing
results seven million new jobs look at
your screen that is what the president's
been able to accomplish despite the
constant unyielding resistance from the
deep state the media mob and a
Democratic Party that does nothing to
original a Supreme Court from the list
he gave us wages hit a post recession
high jobless claims the lowest since
1969 record low unemployment for African
Americans Asian Americans Hispanic
Americans women in the workplace and
youth unemployment were
energy-independent for the first time in
75 years and you know I can go on and on
promises made promises kept this
is what 2020 is really about you will
have the final say not them it's not a
phony witch-hunt you know send it around
a non whistleblower whistleblower